E aí
[Música]
oh Que honra está aqui hoje com vocês
muito obrigada pela presença de todos eu
quero fazer uma questionamento Qual que
é a dupla favorita de alimentos que não
pode faltar na mesa da família
brasileira arroz e feijão é isso mesmo e
como sabemos disso por causa dos dados e
por causa dos dados nós também sabemos
que o Brasil é o maior produtor de
feijão mas também é o maior consumidor
de feijão e o Supermercados os
restaurantes que não deixam faltar esse
prato e o próprio Gosto Popular não nos
deixa mentir não é mesmo o ponto aqui é
com acúmulo de dados a gente consegue
ver melhor as informações a gente
consegue ver de forma diferente e de uma
a maneira E com isso a gente conseguiu
muito tranquilamente notar algo que já
está nesse caso muito Óbvio para um
brasileiro que são os pratos mais
queridinhos do nosso país e claro
considerando aqui no Nordeste não pode
faltar a farofa no mesmo e Big Data você
já ouviram falar nesse termo Talvez sim
talvez não Big Data é uma acúmulo grande
de dados e para quem nunca ouviu falar
ótimo mas para quem já ouviu certamente
já escutou alguma coisa ruim a respeito
isso é lamentável porque essa ferramenta
ela é muito importante para nossa
sociedade avançar mais e mais
e no passado a gente tinha poucos dados
e a gente não conseguia coletar muita
informação e fazer uma transformação
social no entanto hoje na era do Big
Data na era da informação é plenamente
possível
e inclusive é possível que através da
boa utilização dos dados a gente consiga
acabar ou pelo menos nos prevenir de
determinadas situações que estão
acometendo o nosso planeta por exemplo o
aquecimento global também questões
envolvendo eletricidade e energia e até
a própria distribuição de alimentos no
planeta que é um assunto de extrema
relevância não menos importante o
cuidado com a medicina da população o
tratamento de pandemias por exemplo que
é o que a gente tá vivendo nos tempos de
hoje e nesse ano de 2020
Ah e por que a revolução de dados ela é
tão importante essa revolução que também
é conhecida como dataísmo para responder
isso eu vou contar uma história para
vocês é importante que vocês conheçam
primeiro como que era gravado os dados
como que eles eram fisicamente em muitos
tempos atrás Vamos nas origens em 1908
nem tanto tempo atrás assim um
arqueólogo descobriu esse disco 1 disco
chamado disco de festos ele é feito
totalmente de argila e se você observar
bem essa gravura essa imagem e esse
objeto ele possui diversas gravuras
parte delas nunca foram entendidas por
ninguém ainda é um grande mistério o
outro grande mistério é que isso esse
disco ele é referente a 2.200 anos atrás
ou seja quatro mil anos depois nos
o quê lá atrás a sociedade a humanidade
as pessoas que viviam atrás ela já se
comunicavam através do registro de dados
com a sua linguagem da época
e a sociedade portanto não avançaram
tanto assim os discos o disco só mudou a
forma agora é muito mais fácil
transferir documentação Transferir dados
a informação tá lá todo momento ela é
muito mais rápida buscar é mais facil
copiar é mais fácil compartilhar é mais
fácil processadores mais fáceis e muito
mais ages saímos do universo estático
estamos caminhando e vivendo esse
universo fluido dinâmico e líquido a
informação hoje a líquida ela se dissipa
ela vai vem com muita facilidade Vejam a
diferença e o contraste do disco de
Creta e disco de fetos com o caso do
Edward Snowden que conseguiu através de
um pendrive do tamanho de um dedo
espalhar informações secretas do governo
americano da
e do governo americano em tempo
praticamente real
bom então por que temos tantos dados
atualmente houve uma transição uma
transmissão de informações que não eram
transformadas em dados e hoje já existem
essas informações em grande escala como
a gente vai perceber no próximo exemplo
quem é ele Marco Aurélio Marco Aurélio o
Imperador Ele viveu em 180 depois de
Cristo e nessa época como é que a gente
encontrava Marco Aurélio pessoal a gente
precisava ir atrás dele a gente não
sabia onde era a localização nas redes
sociais ou com clique a gente não
consegui encontrá-lo tão pouco a gente
conseguiu colocar o endereço do Império
dele no GPS isso não existia era preciso
ir em busca dele no mínimo uma caneta de
pena e um e o dia inteiro para que a
gente houvesse tivesse obtivesse
registro da fala da sabedoria
o criador
e sabendo disso hoje é completamente
diferente em contraste a gente sabe que
as empresas de telefonia elas armazenam
elas guardam diversas informações e
dados sobre a sua localização mas não só
as empresas de telefonia o seu
smartphone na sua mão te seguindo o
tempo todo ele mostra de ponta a ponta
onde você esteve várias vezes ao dia com
muita precisão e em diversos horários
é um outro exemplo os sensores
o Imagine a seguinte situação imagine um
veículo e diversos sensores mais de 100
sensores espalhados em cada canto dos
acolchoados do seu veículo seja no link
que está ali no motorista seja no
passageiro no banco da frente no banco
de trás imagine um carro repleto de
sensores o que é que pode trazer Qual
resultado esses sensores Podem trazer de
positivo para a sociedade ele pode
construir um índice único para cada um
de nós como espécie de impressão digital
só que vejam não é mais a nossa
biometria não é mais o nosso dedo então
através de outras detalhamentos e outros
outros dados que se sensores captam
a e agora exemplos mais concretos O que
é que se sensores poderiam trazer de
vantajoso na nossa sociedade o que ele
já estão fazendo por exemplo está
evitando que pais deixem os seus filhos
ou esqueçam seus filhos pais ou mães que
são seus filhos dentro do veículo esse
sensores eles podem acabar de vez com
essa situação Terrível ele também pode
ajudar diretamente já o faz na segurança
porque ele pode identificar quem está
ali Pilotando o veículo e através desses
sensores zíper ínterim através de
sensores e brincar ele gentis ele sabe
que não é o condutor e proprietário dos
veículos sendo assim ele simplesmente
desliga o motor e para que o carro
continue a andar existe o envio de uma
segunda chave de autenticação um código
uma senha algo que precisa ser com um
clique ativado no veículo para
e retome o funcionamento Olha que
interessante e como que isso funciona
diretamente está diretamente ligado a
uma segurança muito. É a identificação
da postura Nossa no veículo se a gente
tá com postura ereta e começa a deslizar
no banco o quê que isso pode significar
perante os dados claramente significa
que essa pessoa pode estar prestes a
dormir a cochilar e um acidente em
consequência pode acontecer esses
sensores esses dados eles podem evitar
que um grave acidente aconteça vocês
entendem a importância disso já existe
toda essa informação todos esses dados
sensor já estão sendo testados
implementados no mercado uma das
empresas muito conhecidas é a pérola que
tem a foto aí na imagem Então qual o
valor da Big Data
e qual o valor dessa desse acúmulo de
dados em grande quantidade que a gente
já conseguiu perceber alguns mas agora
eu vou entrar em um dos meus preferidos
e um dos que mais impressiona a
humanidade que é o machine learning
Machine ellone significa aprendizado de
máquina e porque em poucas palavras ele
é tão importante o que que ele faz o que
ele tem de diferente uma assim Guilherme
dormir aqui é um ramo da Inteligência
Artificial que possíveis pertence a
ciência da computação Ele simplesmente
deixa joga o problema para máquina
resolver e ele resolva sozinho Mach Lane
aprendizado de máquina ele traz os seus
aprendizados e vai nos surpreendendo
muitas vezes inclusive com os resultados
é mas eu vou contar um pouquinho da
origem porque vai fazer todos entenderem
muito melhor muito mais como que isso
está sendo construído o Arthur cemu
cientista da Computação da IBM em 1950
nem tanto tempo assim atrás ele que foi
um dos Pioneiros para descobrir a ele
que foi um dos primeiros descobriu
aprendizado de máquina Ele simplesmente
gostava muito de jogar dama e decidiu
por sua vez um dia ensinar um computador
a jogar para daí que ele pudesse jogar e
interagir com essa máquina e assim
aconteceu Ele começou a jogar e o
computador perdia ele puxa vida que eu
vou fazer eu vou ensinar essa máquina a
estratégia ensinando a máquina a
estratégia ele continuou ganhando da
máquina
Olá tudo bem mas ela foi melhorando a
partir dos melhores na sequência o que
aconteceu o Arthur cemu ele decidiu
deixar a máquina jogar sozinha e
aprender sozinha eles aí o ponto logo
depois quando foram jogar novamente ele
perdeu e ele perdeu e ele perdeu e nesse
momento o ar do Samba percebeu O Poder
do aprendizado de máquina e acabou
criando uma espécie muito mais
inteligente e poderosa e estratégica nas
damas muito mais do que o seu próprio
criador e agora eu questiono vocês que
você tão jurídicos e já pararam para
pensar o que que está acontecendo desde
2014 foi criado uma inteligência
artificial que traz toda essa tecnologia
de aprendizado de máquina que a gente já
falou aqui chamado Ross esse Ross ele
foi contratado vocês vão ver logo mais
em
um grande banca jurídica lá em Nova York
e ele resolve e ele resolve diversos
problemas ele foi ele consegue
interpretar leis reúne provas Extra
interferências e responde rapidamente
qualquer chamado que o advogado precise
ele não veio para tirar o espaço do
advogado ele veio para melhorar o
trabalho do advogado ele veio para
provar que ele consegue fazer esse
trabalho duro que a gente passa 10:15
horas eu como advogado a sei bem disso
estudando um caso e buscando informação
para defesa e melhor defesa do nossos
clientes Além disso e diretamente
proporcional ele traz mais eficiência
agilidade economia e tempo dos
profissionais não só tempo de qualidade
na produção intelectual mas tempo de
vida tem mais vida para esse
profissional sair fazer outras coisas
ele fica menos preocupada e
A análise dos julgamentos mais rápidos e
com mais precisão também chamado de
Analytics essas análises elas podem
prever o que o juiz vai decidir e
determinado juízo seja a primeira a
segunda a terceira Instância Isso é uma
grande transformação até porque
normalmente a resposta que não sai da
boca do advogado a depende né a gente
nunca sabe de nada então agora a gente
vai conseguir através dos dados esse
acúmulo de dados dizer algo mais
concreto para o cliente Isso é uma
grande transformação não é unicamente no
setor jurídico que ela está acontecendo
como vocês já viram aqui toda essa
revolução de dados ela tá em diversos
setores mas o jurídico também nos
impressiona e para as diversas
qualidades para nossa sociedade o
advogado vai focar por consequência e
defender seus clientes e ser mais
criativo
ó e além de tudo olha que maravilha essa
máquina trabalha 24 horas por dia sete
dias por semana para você
e esse aqui é uma imagem que reflete os
tempos de hoje nesse momento de pandemia
o CNJ lançou uma portaria a pouquíssimo
tempo atrás um mês atrás e reafirmou a
possibilidade da existência de um juízo
100% digital Olha que interessante isso
ainda é opcional mas eu vou dar um
spoiler para vocês é só ver se a regra
com o passar do tempo a pandemia não nos
deixa mentir muita coisa mudou depois do
covid-19
E aí
e agora não menos importante as sombras
da Big Data quais são elas podemos ser
punidos por conta dessas tantas
previsões e É nesse ponto que a gente
fica precisa ficar atento existe uma e
norte e porte que é a questão das
minorias a questão do racismo por
exemplo policial policiamento preditivo
criminologia algorítmica como resolver
essas questões o problema é quando a
polícia e esses dados invadirem a
questão até mesmo do indivíduo Quando
forem perguntar para esse banco de dados
e analisar se eles estão desempregados e
analisar Qual que é o esporte jurídico
de scorpion bancário deles analisar até
mesmo as úlceras que captam informações
vitais
e tudo isso pode ser analisado para
fazer previsões muitas vezes injustas
isso é uma é um grande ponto focar um
grande ponto de atenção dessa evolução
de dados o problema é ultrapassar
limites do que se conhece sobre o
indivíduo porque a privacidade algo que
o ato diretamente enquanto profissional
Ela já foi o grande problema o grande x
da questão na época dos poucos dados
agora na época dos grandes dados da Big
Data ela vai continuar sendo importante
principalmente vai continuar vindo à
tona Depois dessa recente legislação
chamada lei geral de proteção de dados
no entanto ela não vai ser mais um único
problema a gente precisa agora ter
atenção com a livre arbítrio a escolha
moral a liberdade a violação humana e a
atuação humana quais serão os limites
das relações dessas informações e desses
e quais serão os limites
e Essa sou eu dez anos atrás
recém-formada jovem ainda sou mas eu
ouvi o seguinte do meu do meu chefe há
tempos atrás você meu antigo chefe tá
gente meu único primeiro e único chefe
você vai notar que não conseguirá não
conseguirar você vai notar que não
conseguirá mudar o mundo através da
advocacia olha essa frase me marcou
muito e ainda é muito marcante na minha
vida mas eu tenho uma certeza muito
grande de que sim ele está certo no
entanto eu vou continuar cumprindo meu
papel a minha missão de proteger todos
aqueles todos os direitos a justiça as
virtudes e aquilo que vai buscar a
justiça social essa essa é a minha
missão na sociedade Esse é o legado que
eu quero deixar e portanto Apesar desse
sim ele tem razão eu não vou sucumbir
baixar a cabeça sobre esse assunto meu
papel aqui
a alertar falar continuar a educar temos
que ser os mestres dessa tecnologia e
não os seus criados
e vamos juntos tornar a Revolução dos
dados uma revolução humana Muito
obrigado a
E aí